[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من مخيم عين الحلوه
في لبنان مع بدء القوه الفلسطينيه تنفيذ
خطه ميدانيه لتثبيت وقف اطلاق النار بعد
اربعه ايام من الاشتباكات في المخيم
والى البيت الابيض الان ومن هناك قال منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي انه لا توجد مؤشرات على
ان روسيا هي من يقف وراء الانقلاب في
النيجر او انها تدعمه باي شكل فاعل
والان الى موسكو وتطورات ميدانيات تشير
الى انها كانت في مرمى المسيرات للمره
الثالثه خلال اسبوع واحد مع اعلان وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجمات اوكرانيه
استهدفت مواقع في العاصمه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
وسط توتر في الضفه الغربيه اصابه سته
اسرائيليين في هجوم بمستوطنه شرق القدس
واستشهاد المنفذ فصائل فلسطينيه تعتبر
العمليه ردا على الممارسات الاسرائيليه
الاحتلال يقتل فلسطينيا في جنوب الضفه
بزعم تنفيذه عمليه الطعم وبنجف يطالب
بتوسيع تسليح الاسرائيليين
غداه اعتبار مالي وبوركينا فاسو اي تدخل
خارجي لاعاده حكومه بازوم اعلان حرب بدء
اجلاء رعايه فرنسيين واوروبيين من النيجر
مع الابقاء على القوات الاجنبيه
يقول انه على تواصل وثيق مع العسكريين في
النيجر ويؤكد عدم سحب اي قوه امريكيه من
هناك
في اعتراف نادر باستهداف العمق الروسي
اوكرانيا تقر بتنفيذ الهجمات على موسكو
ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقول انها احبطت
هجوما اوكرانيا جديدا بالمسيرات على موسكو
والبحر الاسود
معارك محتدمه في مدن العاصمه السودانيه
الثلاث الجيش يستهدف تجمعات الدعم السريع
في بحري وام درمان بالطائرات والمدفعيه
والمواجهات بين الجانبين تتوسع في شمال
كردفان ووسط دارفور
وفي لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التداعيات ومؤشرات عمليه
جديده نفذها شاب فلسطيني في مستوطنه
شرقي القدس لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم هذا السؤال
برايكم الى ماذا يشير تصاعد العمليات ضد
المستوطنين وتبني الفصائل لها الاجابه
كانت على الشكل التالي
52% قالوا ان تصاعد العمليات يشير الى
تحول في استراتيجيه الفصائل الفلسطينيه
بينما قال نحو خمسه وثلاثين في المئه انه
يشير الى تطور ضمن حلقه التصعيد والتصعيد
المضاد
اما ثلاثه عشر في المئه فيعتقدون ان
التصاعد مؤشر جديد على اخفاق امنيا
اسرائيلي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوريا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول انها ابلغت وفضه
طالبان في محادثات الدوحه بضروره عدم
استخدام افغانستان منصه لشن هجمات ارهابيه
ومصدر حكومي افغاني يؤكد الاتفاق على
الاستمرار في اللقاءات بين الوفد
[موسيقى]
ونبدا من الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وحاله من التوتر المتزايد هناك اذ اصيب
سته اسرائيليين اثنان منهم في حاله خطيره
في عمليه اطلاق نار بمستوطنه ادوميم شرقي
القدس واكدت شرطه الاحتلال انه تمت تصفيه
المنفذ من جهه طالب وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيليه ماربين جفير من مكان العمليه
بتسليح اكبر عدد من الاسرائيليين
تجمع ما بعد الحدث والحدث مسرحه مستوطنه
مع علي ادوميم شرقي القدس المحتله
انها واحده من كبرى الكتل الاستيطانيه
بالضفه الغربيه وهي اكثرها توسعا منذ
تاسيسها
هنا وقعت احدث عمليه اطلاق نار اصيب فيها
سته اسرائيليين قيل ان حال اثنين منهم
خطره
اما الشاب الفلسطيني العشريني منفذ
العمليه مهند المزارعه فارتقى شهيدا بعد
اطلاق جنود الاحتلال النار عليه
ليس من شك في ان الضربه في قلب التجمعات
الاستيطانيه يشكل اختراقا وتحديا للمنظومه
الامنيه والعسكريه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لكن على المستوى السياسي في اسرائيل لن
يعدم الحدث مستثمرين فيه بين اكثر اقطاب
حكومه نتنياهو تطرفا كدابه يهرول وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي الى موقع اطلاق
النار اتمار وجدها سانحه للمطالبه من هنا
بتسليح اكبر عدد من الاسرائيليين قال ان
السياسه توزيع الاسلحه التي تقودها وزارته
في هذا الصدد هي سياسه مهمه اثبتت نفسها
اما ما ثبت في الجانب الفلسطيني فهو ان
فعل المقاومه مستمر هكذا باركت فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عمليه مستوطنه
واعتبرتها ردا على الاحتلال وممارساته
العمليه كما تراها حركه حماس تاتي دفاعا
عن المسجد الاقصى وردا على اقتحامات
المستوطنين
واكدت حماس ان ضربات الثائرين والمقاومين
لن تتوقف دفاعا عن ارض فلسطين ومقدساتها
وافشال مخططات حكومه الاحتلال
حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه اعتبرت من جانبها
ان عمليه معاليها
بالفدائيه البطوليه جاءت ردا طبيعيا على
العدوان الاسرائيلي وقالت الجهاد ان الشعب
الفلسطيني يثبت ان ارادته اقوى من كل
المؤامرات التي تستهدف اشغاله عن مواجهه
العدو والتصدي له اما الجبهه الشعبيه
لتحرير فلسطين فرات ان العمليه تعبير عن
وعي الانسان الفلسطيني بارضه وهويته
وحقيقه الصراع القائم مع العدو دفاعا عن
الوجود والارض
كلمات الفصائل تخدم المعنى ذاته لكل فعل
رد فعل وقد كثر الفعل في عهد ما توصف
باكثر حكومات اسرائيل تطرفا لا يبدا الامر
بمحاولات التهويد والاستهتار بالمقدسات
ولا ينتهي بمصادره الاراضي وتعزيز
الاستيطان
كما اطلقت قوه الاحتلال النار على شاب
فلسطيني جنوب مدينه الخليل المحتله بذريعه
تنفيذه عمليه الطعن في محطه للحافلات وقال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قتل المنفذ دون وقوع
اصابات في صفوف جنوده
ينضم الان الينا من رام الله هاني المصري
مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث السياسات
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه استاذ هاني اهلا
بك في الحصاد اذا هذه العمليه والوصول الى
مستوطنه معالي ادوميم اليوم متبني الفصائل
لها ماذا تقول فلسطينيه
هذه العمليه تقول ان كل العدوان
الاسرائيلي وكل التطرف الاسرائيلي
والقوانين العنصريه والحديث عن الحسم وغير
ذلك من تجديد العقوبات على الاسرى وكل ما
تقوم به الحكومه الاسرائيليه يرتد عليها
باستمرار المقاومه وتصاعد المقاومه ووقوع
قتل اسرائيليين في عهد هذه الحكومه اكثر
من اي حكومه سابقه وبالتالي الشعب
الفلسطيني قدم جوابه وهو مستعد لمواصله
الصمود ومواصله المقاومه وهو بحاجه الى
قياده تحمي يعني هذه المقاومه بحاجه الى
جبهه وطنيه تحمي هذه المقاومه بحاجه الى
استراتيجيه سياسيه ونضاليه تقود هذه
المقاومه حتى تستثمر لان الشعب الفلسطيني
يريد من المقاومه ان تحقق اهدافه ان تحقق
مصالحه ان تمنع تطبيق المخططات
الاسرائيليه لانك مع كل يوم يمر هناك
المزيد من المستوطنات المزيد من هدم
المنازل المزيد من الاعتقالات المزيد من
الحصار والمعاناه الكبيره التي يعاني منها
الشعب الفلسطيني وقع استراتيجيه جديده
للفصائل هل تغيير في الطريقه التي تتعامل
بها من الان فصاعدا بدانا نشهده فعليا
للاسف
للاسف بعد اجتماع العلمين اخفقت الفصائل
بالاتفاق على استراتيجيه واحده بل فشلت
فشلا ذريعا وحاولت ان تغطي يعني فشلها
بالحديث عن قرار تشكيل لجنه للمتابعه اي
ارضيه لهذه اللجنه اي مرجعيه لهذه اللجنه
اذا كانت مقررات المجلس الوطني والمركزي
لا تعتبر مرجعيه فكيف يمكن ان يتحاور
المتحاورون ولكن على الفصائل الاخرى التي
تتبنى الخيار المقاومه ان تبلور هذه
الاستراتيجيه ان توحد جهودها لانه حتى
داخل الفصائل المقاومه لا يوجد استراتيجيه
واحده هناك نظره مختلفه ما بين من يريد ان
يكون هناك تهدئه في غزه وتصعيد في الضفه
او ان يكون هناك يعني اكثر من ممارسه
للمقاومه بحكم اعباء السلطه في غزه هذا
امر بحاجه ان يوضع على طاوله الفلسطينيين
ان استمراره يمكن ان يزيد الشرخ وينقله
الى فصائل اخرى بدلا من ان نوحنا ان
الاستراتيجيه على
الطرف تماما وراسخه
على الاقل هو يقول التسليح ثم التسليح بل
يريد مزيد من التسليح وكان المستوطنين هو
الاسرائيليين بشكل عام يعني ليسوا اصلا
بالسلاح حاليا فمن عن اي تسليح يتحدث
توسيع للتسليح
نعم معك حق هناك 200 الف مستوطن مسلح في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله وهناك مئات الالاف
من الاسرائيليين الذين يحملون السلاح
المرخص وغير المرخص في داخل اراضي 48
وبالتالي لا ينقصهم السلاح ينقصهم ان
يردعوا الفلسطينيين وهذا هدف يعني بعيد
المنال ولم يتحقق في السابق واعتقد انه لن
يتحقق حاليا الطريقه الوحيده لانهاء
المقاومه هو انهاء الاحتلال وتحقيق الحقوق
الفلسطينيه وهذه الحكومه تصور انها قادره
على الحسم وضم الضفه والتهجير والتهويل
وهدم الاقصى هناك يعني حكومه تبدو انها
يعني منفصله عن الواقع والمساله ليست
مساله فقط بن كبير يقف ورائهم نتنياهو
ولكن نتيجه خبرته السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
يحاول ان يظهر بمظهر مختلف ولكن بدون دعم
نتنياهو لا يمكن لهؤلاء ان يكونوا في
المواقع التي احتلوها في الحكومه ولا يمكن
ان يكونوا هم المؤثرين على قراءه الحكومه
ويظهر نتنياهو وكانه ضحيه في حين انه هو
مجرم وجلاد هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات
لابحاث السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
من رام الله
[موسيقى]
بدات فرنسا اجلاء رعاياها والمواطنين
الاوروبيين الراغبين في مغادره النيجر اما
في الولايات المتحده فقالت وزاره الدفاع
انها على تواصل وفيق مع العسكريين في
النيجر واكدت عدم سحب اي قوات امريكيه من
هناك وتستمر سلطات نيامي الجديده في
احتجاز الرئيس وسط شد وجذب بين منظمه
الاكواس من جهه وحكومتي مالي وبوركينا
فاسو
يتاكدوا هذا العسكري من قوائم المسافرين
المسموح لهم بدخول مطار امامه المغلقي منذ
ايام لقد اصبح الخروج يحتاج الى اذن اذن
بدات فرنسا اجلاء الاوروبيين من العاصمه
الحائره بين مؤيد الرئيس المنقلب عليه
محمد بازوم وقاده الانقلاب
الخارجيه الامريكيه لا ترى خطرا على
الامريكيين داخل النيجر لكنها تهيب بحكام
البلاد كي يسمحوا للرعايه بالخروج
اما مواطن النيجر فيتابعون تلويح دول
الايكواس بالتدخل العسكري في بلادهم اذا
لم يفرج العسكر عن الرئيس ويعيد البلاد
لمساريرها الديمقراطي لكن مالي وبوركينا
فاسو اللتين سبقتها النيجر الى الانقلابات
اعتبرتها اي تدخل عسكري في نيامه بمثابه
اعلان حرب عليهما
نحذر من ان اي تدخل عسكري في النيجر سيكون
اعلان حرب على بوركينا فاسو ومالي كما
سيقود لانسحاب الدولتين من الاكواس وسيؤدي
الى اجراءات دفاعيه تقود لمساعده القوات
في النيجر نحذر من ان اي تدخل عسكري في
النيجر سيقود لزعزعه الامن في المنطقه كما
وقع بعد تدخل الناتو في ليبيا مما نشر
الارهاب في منطقه الساحل وغرب افريقيا
كلها
ما يزال بازو محتجزا قرب قصره الرئاسي
لكنه ممتع بالاتصال الخارجي ومتابعه
الاخبار وما تزال التصريحات الدوليه غالبا
تقف الى جانبه
الانقلاب في النيجر فهو تهديد للديمقراطيه
وزرع للقلاقل وندعو الى الافراج الفوري عن
الرئيس بازوم وعائلته وحاشيته
استمرار اغلاق الحدود قد يسفر خلال الفتره
القادمه عن نقص في المواد الاساسيه في هذه
الدوله الحبيسه المعتمده على الواردات من
دول الجوار اما صادراتها فمحدوده نوعا
وزباء
يمكنني التاكيد انه لن يكون لدى
الاوروبيين نقص في اليورانيوم الطبيعي
فلدينا منه ما يكفي لتعويض اي نقص على
المدى القصير اما على المدى المتوسط ففي
سوق العالميه ما يكفي لتغطيه حاجاتنا
وسط كل هذا يسود غموض هويه المنقلبين وسط
رفع بعض المتظاهرين اعلاما روسيه ومحاولات
اقتحام السفاره الفرنسيه وهي نفس الخطوات
التي قام بها انقلابي مالي وبركينا فاسو
وغينيا من قبل
وينضم الان الينا من واشنطن السفير
كيري لمن نجري سفير النيجر لدى واشنطن
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد السفير
واسالك في البدايه ما حجم الرهان على
الموقف الدولي لاعاده الامور الى مكانه
عليه في النيجر قبل الانقلاب
على الموقف الدولي بالنسبه الى النيجر لا
اعتقد انه
رهان الان بل هناك موقف واضح وموحد على
المستوى الدولي على مستوى الاتحاد
الافريقي وهو الموقف الاقليمي الذي سلطت
عليه الضوء ايضا المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غرب افريقيا والولايات والامم المتحده
اوضحت الموقف بشكل لا لبس فيه بالاضافه
الى كل خلفائنا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه والمانيا
وفرنسا كل شركاء النيجر على المستوى دوري
توحدوا في موقفهم الداعي الى وقف هذه
المحاوله الانقلابيه واعاده وتحرير الرئيس
المحتجز كرهينه من قبل الانقلابيين
واعاده السلطه الى السلطات المنتخبات
الديمقراطيا في البلاد ولكن السؤال كيف هل
سيكون ذلك عبر تدخل عسكري ام كما تقول
واشنطن ما زالت هناك نافذه
للدبلوماسيه وهي تتحدث
العسكريين الموجودين حاليا
اي الطريقين ترى انهما الارجح الان
هناك فرصه من اجل
الدبلوماسيه بما ان المجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول غرب افريقيا اعلنت العقوبات مع مهله
زمنيه وشروط وبالتالي يعود الامر الى
التغمه العسكريه لكي تعرف ان هذه المغامره
وادت الى معاناه غير مطلوبه ويمكن تفاديها
للشعب
وتعود الى التعقل ولكي تستمع الى جهود
الجهات التي تقوم بالوساطه وان تعيد
السلطه الى الرئيس محمد بازوم المنتخب
بشكل شرعي وديمقراطي بالاضافه
للسلطات التابعه لي جمهوريه النيجر
والعوده الى السكنات العسكريه لقيام
بعملهم فهو الدفاع عن بلادنا وحمايه
مؤسساتنا عوضا عن الهجوم على مؤسساتنا
واخذ الرئيس المنتخب
رهينه على وجه الخصوص
التفاوض والدبلوماسيه من الذي يقود هذه
الجهود من
هو الاكبر فرصه للوصول ربما وايصال صوته
للانقلابيين لكي ربما يستمع ويتفاوضوا من
وتر سلطه الاكبر في منطقتنا تحدثت نحن
تحدثت عن مؤتمر
الرؤساء الدول المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غرب افريقيا
انت تحدثت عن هذه المنظمه اذا سمحت لان
اقاطعك هنا تاشرت اليها في اكثر من اجابه
ولكن اتضح وخصوصا بالامس في ساعات الليل
الاخيره كان هناك موقف يدل على ان الاكواس
ليست على قلب رجل واحد فيما يتعلق بالنيجر
بل ان هناك تصريحات خاصه عبرت عن عدم
دعمها لهذا الموقف ما تعليقكم على ذلك
نعم نتحدث عن الدولتين اعلنت الحرب اذا في
وجه المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
ولكننا نتحدث عن دولتين اصلا السلطه فيهما
غير شرعيه لانها اتت بعد انقلاب عسكري
الاول هو بسيطره من فاجنر الروسيه ميليشيا
فاجنر
وهذه هتان الدولتان هددتا ولكن هذا لا
يغير اذا منسحبت من المجموعه مجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدولي غربي
وبوركينا فاس ولكن غينيا كوناكري ايضا
دينا كوناكري ايضا تحدثت عن احتمال
الانقسام في الاكواس بهذا الشان ولكن اسمح
لي سؤال اخير يتعلق
المغامره كما وصفتها انت انت تقول ان هناك
اطراف
وجهات قامت بمغامره في النيجر ولكن هل هذه
الاطراد تحركت بمفردها ام كان هناك دعم من
قوى خارجيه ومن هي
سته
هذه المحاوله
الانقلابيه لا شيء يبررها لا شيء يبررها
بالنسبه الى التراجع تراجع الاوضاع
الامنيه وهذا ما قالته تغمى العسكريه هذا
خطا حيث انه من بعد ما استلم السيد بازون
زمام الرئاسه الوضع تحسن ما من هجمات في
خلال رئاسه السيد عندما تتحدث هذه
المجموعه عن ازمه اقتصاديه هذا غير صحيح
النمو الاقتصادي في العام 2022 كان بنسبه
سبعه بالمئه وكانت المدارس تعمل
للمره الاولى منذ خمسه عشره سنه لم نشهد
فيها اضرابات على مستوى المدارس هل هناك
قوه خارجيه دعمت هذا التحرك
هل كانت هناك قوى خارجيه تدعم هذا التحرك
عليك ان تطرحي السؤال على المجموعه هي اذا
ما كان هناك
جهه خلف هذه المجموعه اذا هذه المغامره
يجب ان تنتهي بوقف معاناه شعبي بلادنا
اشكرك السفير
السفير
كيري لمن تنجيري سفير النيجر لدى واشنطن
شكرا على وجودك معنا
وارحب الان من عاصمه النيجر رانيامي
الدكتور علي يعقوب الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور علي
واريد ان ابدا بسؤالك عن المزاج العام في
الشارع في النيامي بعد سته ايام من وقوع
الانقلاب كيف يمكن وصفه هل هناك تغير ما
باتجاه جهه من دون اخرى
شكرا على الاستضافه اولا بالنسبه لمدينه
نياما الامور فيها هادئه كان ليس فيها شيء
المكاتب الحكوميه مفتوحه والاسواق مفتوحه
وكل شيء
يشير ان هناك مشكله وان كان لما تلتقي
بالناس تتحدث معهم يتحدثون حول اكمال
الحمله العسكريه على البلاد هذا فيلم
تسمعه في المجالس ناس يتحدثون بها وقضيه
حمل العسكريه هذه زادت
الشعب النيه التماسكا ووطنيه اخرى واخاف
او ممكن ان تنقص من شعبيه الرئيس السابق
هو محمد
ولكن يعني امور وطنيه
يعني بصراحه المشهد في نيامي يعني يبدو
غريب يعني لم نعرف انقلابا اخر بهذه
الصوره على الاقل حديثا في الدول الجوار
ايضا الرئيس لديه يعني قدره على التواصل
يجتمع بقاده يتم التحدث معه وكل هذه
الامور كيف يفسر يعني هذا هل هذا يعني ان
هناك باب للحوار مازال مفتوح
وهل فعلا يعني في تاييد لهذا التوجه
صراحه اظن
الانقلابين ارادوا الامور تسير بثلاثه
وبدون انف والا ممكن ان ياخذوه الى مكان
لا يراه احد ولا يتصل باحد
من
يظنون هكذا وافقته لباب الحوار قبل ايام
او يومين كان رئيس كان هنا وسمينا اليوم
في الاخبار ان رئيس
نيجيريا السابق عبد السلام وكذلك امير
المسلمين في نيجيريا في سكوت سيكون مسلمين
لن يعمل غدا لاجراء حوار اخر
ليجدوا حلا للمشكله ولكن الدكتور علي وسط
هذا ايضا في نفس الوقت
هناك اجلاء للرعايه الاجانب هناك حديث عن
تدخل خارجي انت من واقع وجودك يعني في قلب
الحدث هل لاحظت اي مؤشرات تدل على استعداد
من جانب الانقلابيين لم واجهه هكذا تدخل
لا ما في شيء ما في شيء والله في شوارع
التي تجولنا اليوم ما في اي شيء ولا ترى
عسكري ولا سياره عسكري ولا شيء في شوارع
وهؤلاء الاجانب الذين
يجلونهم هذا من بلدانهم لان فرنسا خافت
يوم الاحد شباب ذهبوا الى سفارته فرنسا
وقاموا باعمال حرق والنهب وكسر بعض
الادوات في اشياء في السفاره وهم الى
اضطروا ان يطلقوا عليهم نار المهم هم
خافوا من هذا من هذا لان الشكر عليهم
جاءوا والقوا الكتاب وذهبوا ثم جاء
الاخرون من خلف واقاموا بهذه العمليه
لانهم خافوا من هذا والا ما في شيء او
تراه في الشباب ان هناك هجوم عسكري سيكون
ايضا يا اختي يجب ان نفهم شيء
قالوا اجتمال ما قالوا هجوم عسكري على
النجر مباشره
قد يكون وارثا
على العموم نتابع لان التصريحات كثيره من
اطراف كثيره شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور علي
يعقوب الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي من عاصمه
[موسيقى]
الى روسيا قالت وزاره الدفاع ان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي احبطت محاوله مسيرات استهدفت
مناطق حيويه في وسط موسكو هذا الهجوم هو
الثالث الذي يستهدف العاصمه خلال اسبوع
وفي تصريح اوكرانيا غير مسبوق بشان
الهجمات في العمق الروسي قال امين مجلس
الامن القوميه الاوكرانيه ان بلاده تخوض
حرب رموز فكما استهدفت الطراد موسكو من
قبل استهدف اليوم مبنى موسكو سيتي
وفق المعايير الميدانيه لا يمكن الحديث عن
توسع رقعه القتال المباشر جغرافيا بين
روسيا واوكرانيا لكن المعايير استراتيجيه
للحروب تفرض الحديث عن استهدافات باتت
اكثر توترا
قلب العاصمه موسكو دخل في مرمى المسيرات
الاوكرانيه ثلاثه استهدافات خلال اقل من
اسبوع واحد هذا ما اكدته وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه التي تحدثت عن استهداف منطقه
حيويه احد ابراج منطقه موسكو سيتي
التجاريه وعن ان وحداتها احبطت الهجوم
واسقطت المسيرات لكن اللافت هو ما لم تقله
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وكاله تاس نقلت عما سمته مصدرا رفيع
المستوى في نظام الدفاع الجوي الروسي قوله
ان المسيرات التي اسقطتها انظمه الدفاع
اثناء محاولتها مهاجمه منشات في موسكو
وضواحيها انطلقت من الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
دون تحديد نقطه الانطلاق لكن نظريا فان
اقرب نقطه تحت سيطره الجيش الاوكراني
حاليا عن موسكو هي تشارنيهز في شمال
البلاد والتي تب عد قرابه 800 كم عن
العاصمه الروسيه كخط طيران مباشر هذا يعني
ان المسيرات قطعت هذه المسافه دون ان ترصد
كيف اقرت باطلاق المسيرات وقال المستشار
في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بودولياك
ان الحربه تنتقل اخيرا الى الاراضي
الروسيه
وبينما الصراع مستمر على السيطره على
البحر الاسود حيث تمتلك روسيا اليد العليا
نظرا لتفوقها العسكري الجوي والبحري قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها افشلت محاوله
اوكرانيه لاستهداف سفن مدنيه روسيه في
البحر الاسود
بزوارق مسيره كييف سارعت لنفي استهدافها
اي سفن وقالت انها لم ولم تهاجم اهدافا
مدنيه في البحر
ومنها الان المقدم باتريك بودر الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي في مركز
الاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بك مقدم بودر اذا
اريد ان اسالك عن هذه العمليات ثلاث
عمليات في اسبوع واحد في العمق الروسي ما
الذي تقوله عن استراتيجيه اوكرانيا وعن
مسار الحرب بشكل عام في هذه المرحله
قوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تود ان تاتي
بالحرب الى روسيا لان الشعب الاوكراني
استهدف لاكثر من عام وقد ان الاوان قناه
كما قال الرئيس الاوكراني لكي يشعر الشعب
الروسي بهذا الخوف من خلال استهداف
بنى التحتيه وهذا ما يعاني منه الشعب
الاوكراني وهذا ما تريده القوات
الاوكرانيه الان من خلال هذا
الرد
وهذا ما يود ان يشعر به الشعب الروسي ولكن
السؤال كيف
ذلك
ام انه عدم خبره في التعامل مع المسيرات
كما يقول المتحدث باسم
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه نفسه هو يقول
انه ليس لدي نحن لدينا خبره هم ليس لديهم
خبره لذلك لا يستطيع الرد على هذه
المسيرات
بالنسبه الي هذه
الهجمات
المسيره ان اتت من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
يعني ذلك انها حلقت 800 كم فوق الاراضي
الروسيه وهي لم تسقط من الاجواء وهذا يعني
على الارجح انهما من دفاعات جويه في تلك
الاجزاء من روسيا الجنوبيه لربما كل
الدفاعات الروسيه انتشرت في الاجزاء
المحتله من اوكرانيا للدفاع عن القوات
الروسيه هناك من خلال القيام بهذه الهجمات
تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه ان
تدفع به الروس لتحريك الدفاعات الجويه نحو
الداخل الروسي من اجل التخفيف من
التعزيزات على الاراضي الاوكرانيه كي
تتمكن القوات الاوكرانيه وخصوصا سلاح الجو
يعمل بشكل حر بحريه
اكبر وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن مساله تكتيكيه
عسكريه ايضا وراء استهداف روسيا من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه تحدثت عن العامل النفسي
يعني الضرر الذي تحدثه هذه المسيرات
قليل جدا وصغير جدا بالنسبه للضرر المعنوي
والنفسي الذي تحدث الى اي حد فعلا تنجح
اوكرانيا في استثمار هذا الجانب واستغلاله
لصالحها في الحرب
نعم فهمت ما تقصدين اعتقد ان اوكرانيا ترى
ان الرئيس بوتين يخسر السلطه يخسر القوه
ويخسر المصداقيه خصوصا بعدما حصل مع
مجموعه
على الارجح وضعه متارجح بشكل اكبر
والقوات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تستغل هذه
الثغرات في روسيا حيث ان سلطه الرئيس
بوتين تهتز وهناك ايضا محاوله لحشد الشعب
الروسي في وجهه الرئيس بوتين طبعا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه
تعرضت او تقول انها لا تستهدف المدنيين
وهي تعرضت من خلال منشات في اوكرانيا
تعرضت المنشات في اوكرانيا المدنيه لهجمات
روسيه ولكن القوات الاوكرانيه لا ترد
بالمثل بل تستهدف المنشات من دون ان يكون
هناك ضحايا بالمدنيين او باوساط المديين
اذا لا تودوا اوكرانيا ان تؤذي الروس ولكن
تود ان تسلط الضوء على ما يحصل في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بسبب تصرفاته الرئيس الروسي
اشكرك المقدم باتريك
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى السودان الان حيث افاد مراسل للجزيره
انا الجيش قصف بالمدفعيات تجمعات للدعم
السريع في منطقه بحر شمالي الخرطوم وقال
مصدر عسكري في الجيش للجزيره ان الطائرات
الحربيه قصفت اليوم المنطقه المحيطه
بالمدينه الرياضيه التي انطلقت منها
الشراره الاولى للحرب ومن جهه اخرى فادت
مصادر ومحليه للجزيره ان الجيش نفذ ضربات
على اهداف للدعم السريع في ضاحيه الجريف
شرقي الخرطوم
كما قالت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان قواتها
الجيش السوداني هاجمت نقطه ارتكاز لقوات
الدعم السريع في مدخل مدينه ام روايه في
شمال كردفان روابى عفوا ام روابه
وذلك على الطريق المؤدي لمدينه الابيض
وبحسب المصادر ادى الهجوم لسقوط قتلى
وجرحى من جانب الدعم السريع
وفي محور اخر قال مصدر عسكري في الجيش
السوداني للجزيره ان واحدا وعشرين عنصرا
من الدعم السريع قتلوا واصيب 41 كما تم
اسر 17 منهم بمدينه زرنجي وسط دارفور
وذكر المصدر العسكريين فرقه 21 في الجيش
السوداني في المدينه تصدت لهجوم شنته قوات
الدعم السريع من محورين
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الحكومه السعوديه دعما اقتصاديا
جديدا لليمن بمليار ومئتين مليون دولار
وذلك من خلال البرنامج السعودي للاعمار
وتنميه اليمن وقالت الرياضه ان هذا الدعم
سيسهم في تحسين الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
وحمايتها من الانهيار كما يساعد في تعزيز
امني واستقرار اليمن واشارت الى ان هذا
الدعم ياتي بناء على طلب من الحكومه
اليمنيه لمعالجه عجز الموازنه ودعما لمجلس
القياده الرئاسي
هذا وقال سفير المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في اليمن المشرفه العام على البرنامج
السعودي لتنميه واعمار اليمن محمد ال جابر
ان السعوديه قدمت دعما للحكومه اليمنيه
بقيمه مليار و200 مليون دولار واضاف
جابر ان الدعم سيساعد في تحقيق الامن
الغذائي لليمني
هذه الاتفاقيه تدعم الوضع الاقتصادي في
نفس الوقت تدعم ايضا فرص السلام وايضا
تدعم الشعب اليمني في كل محافظات بما
يساعد في تحسين وضعها المعيشي وتحسين
الوضع الغذائي بالاضافه الى ايضا توفير
المشتقات النفطيه لمحطات الكهرباء
المختلفه من خلال استخدام جزء يسير من هذا
من هذا الدعم لتغطيه مشتريات المشتقات
النفطيه من قبل الحكومه اليمنيه
ومن جهه قلا وزير الماليه اليمني سالم بن
بريك ان الدعم ان الدعم السعودي لليمن
سيخفف من الوضع الاقتصادي والانساني الحرج
الذي تعيشه البلاد واضاف بن بريكه ان
الحكومه اليمنيه فقدت 65% من ايراداتها
نتيجه استهداف جماعه الحوث للمنشات
النفطيه بحسب تعبيره
التوقيع الاتفاقيه الان على مليار و200
مليون دولار وهذا سيتخفف بالوضع الاقتصادي
يعني
الحرج اللي نحن فيه الان والوضع الانساني
وهذا نتيجه استهداف الميليشيا الحوثيه
للمنشات تصدير النفط التي فقدت الميزانيه
العامه للدوله حوالي 65% من ايراداتها
ولكن وتاثرت الاقتصاد وتاثرت الميزانيه
العامه ولكن هذا الدعم ان شاء الله سيخفف
ويعني يرفع الكثير من من الضغط التي على
الاقتصاد اليمني كامله
قبل المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه مافيو ميلر ان وفدا امريكيا بحث
مع قاده طالبان في الدوحه مساله اطلاق
سراح الامريكيين المحتجزين في افغانستان
واضاف ميلر ان الوفدين بحث كذلك عددا من
المسائل الاخرى بينها استئناف الرحلات
الجويه ومكافحه المخدرات والارهاب
في الاجتماع مع قاده طالبان اثرنا عددا من
القضايا من بينها استئناف الطيران ومكافحه
المخدرات ومحاربه الارهاب وواصلنا الضغطه
من اجل الافراج عن المحتجزين لكن احتراما
لخصوصيتهم لا يمكنني الخوض في ظروفهم
الخاصه
هذا وكان مصدر في الحكومه الافغانيه
المؤقته قال للجزيره ان الوفد الافغانيين
ناقش مع وفدا امريكيا في الدوحه قضيه
اطلاق سراحهم المواطنين امريكيين في
السجون الافغانيه واشار المصدر الى موافقه
واشنطن على منح المزارعين الافغان مساعدات
ماليه بدل زراعه الخشخاش
وفي سياق اخر اجتمع وفد بريطانيا بممثلين
من الحكومه الافغانيه للافراج عن معتقلين
بريطانيين لدى افغانستان
هذا وقالت الخارجيه القطريه ان وزيره
الدوله للتعاون الدولي لول والخاطر التقت
في الدوحه المبعوثه الامريكيه المكلف
بحقوق الانسان في افغانستان والمبعوثه
الامريكيه الخاص الى افغانستان بحضور
السفير الامريكي لدى الدوحه وبحسب
الخارجيه القطريه فان اللقاء بحث علاقات
التعاون بين البلدين ونتائج الاجتماعات
الامريكيه الافغانيه التي استضافتها
الدوحه وكذلك سبل دعم قطاعات الصحه
والتعليم والاقتصاد في افغانستان
اعربت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه عن قلقها
الشديد بشانه اوضاع الزميلين ربيع الشيخ
وبهاء الدين ابراهيم في السجون المصريه
وقالت الشبكه في بيان ان زميلين ربيع
الشيخ وبهاء الدين ابراهيم تعرضا خلال
اعتقالهما في السجون المصريه لانتهاكات
قانونيه وقد حملت الشبكه السلطات المصريه
المسؤوليه الكامله عن سلامه الزميلين
كما نظمت شبكه الجزيره وقفه تضامنيه مع
صحفييها المعتقلين في السجون المصريه ربيع
الشيخ وبهاء الدين ابراهيم ودعت الهيئات
المعنيه بحريه الصحافه للمطالبه بالافراج
الفوري عنهما دون تهمه واضحه وقد استنكرت
شبكه الجد
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هيئه العمل الفلسطيني المشترك في
لبنان بعد اجتماع ضم ممثلين عن كافه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في مقر سفاره فلسطين
في بيروت عن التوصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق
النار في مخيم عين الحلوه وقال فتحي ابو
العردات امين سر حركه فتح في لبنان ان
الاتفاق يقوم على سحب المسلحين وتكليف
لجنه تحقيق لكشف المتورطين في مقتل قائد
الامن الوطني الفلسطيني في صيدا
تكليف لجنه التحقيق المعينه
والمشكله من هيئه العمل الفلسطيني المشترك
المباشره الفوريه بعمله بعملها للكشف عن
المتورطين المجرمين في ارتكاب الجريمه
التي حصلت لتقديمهم للجهات القضائيه
والامنيه اللبنانيه
وانجاز مهمتها باسرع وقت ممكن ورفع
تقريرها لهيئه العمل الفلسطيني المشترك
هذا وكانت الاشتباكات قد اندلعت في عدد من
احياء مخيم عين الحلوه وسبقت ذلك فتره
هدوء اعقبت اتفاقا لوقف اطلاق النار
واظهرت صور حصلت عليها الجزيره من داخل
المخيم حجم الاضرار لاسيما في حياي حطين
وبستان القدس داخل المخيم كما تسببت
الاشتباكات في انقطاع خدمات اساسيه عن
سكان المخيم كذلك
لنتعرف على ابرز احداث الاشتباكات التي
دارت في مخيم عين الحلوه للاجئين
الفلسطينيين ضمن العرض التالي
الاشتباكات الجاريه في مخيم عين الحلو
للاجئين الفلسطينيين في لبنان ليست الاولى
من نوعها ففي عام 2011 شهد اشتباكات بين
حركه فتح وتنظيم جند الشام اسفرت عن مقتل
مدنيين احدهما طفل وعادت المواجهات بين
عناصر فتح ومجموعات اسلاميه عام 2016
واستمرت لعده ايام بعد مقتل نشط من عصبه
الانصار
شهد المخيم عده اشتباكات سنه 2017 فبين
شهرين ابريل واغسطس دارت مواجهات بين
عناصر القوه الامنيه المشتركه وحركه فتح
من جهه وبين مجموعات اسلاميه في سنه 2021
عرف المخيم اشتباكات جديده بين فتح
وناشطين اسلاميين على خلفيه قيام مجموعه
من الامن الوطني الفلسطيني باعتقال مطلوب
وتسليمه الى مخابرات الجيش اللبناني
وفي عام 2022 سقط عدد من الجرحى في
اشتباكات بين عائلتين استخدم فيها الرصاص
والقذائف الصاروخيه اما في العام الجاري
وقبل اربعه اشهر قتل عنصر من حركه فتح
واصيب اخرون في اشتباكات مع مسلحين من
تنظيم جند الشام
[موسيقى]
شهد الوجود الفلسطيني والعلاقات اللبنانيه
الفلسطينيه منذ عام 48 مراحل تاريخيه
متفاوته بين الصعود وهبوط وقد راكمت بعض
الايجابيات كما افرزت بعضا من السلبيات
والهواجس المتبادله التي بلغت ذروتها في
ازمه مخيم نهر البارد عام 2007 شمل
التعداد الذي تشارك فيه او تشارك في
انجازه اداره الاحصاء المركزيه اللبنانيه
والجهاز المركزي الفلسطيني للاحصاء باشراف
لجنه الحوار اللبنانيه الفلسطيني
شملت 12 مخيما
ومئه
وسته وخمسين تجمعا سكانيا وهي معظم اماكن
الوجود الفلسطيني في لبنان
يتركز الفلسطينيون استنادا للتعداد على
الاقل في منطقه صيدا جنوبيه لبنان
بنسبه اكثر من 35
في المئه تم في الشمال ثم كذلك في الشمال
بنسبه
25% ما في العاصمه بيروت فتبلغ النسبه
اكثر من 13%
تقع اربعه من المخيمات في بيروت وضواحيها
ومنها برج البراجنه وكذلك هذه هذا المخيم
الواقع في الضحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت وايضا
مخيم شاتيلا ويقع غرب بيروت واساسته
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ويؤوي اكثر
من ثمانيه الاف لاجئ فلسطين
هذا المخيم تاسس عام
1956 في الضاحيه الشرقيه لبيروت
كذلك مخيم ماري الياس هذا المخيم صغير
نسبيا يقع شمال الغربي بيروت وقد تاسس عام
52 وكان معظم سكانه في البدايه من
المسيحيين ثم جاءت موجات تدفق المسلمين
اليه في اعقاب الحرب الاهليه في لبنان
الفلسطينيون في لبنان هم جزء من لجاوا بعد
النكبه عام 48
وقد تجنس جزء كبير منهم في المقابل بلغ
عدد الغير مجنسين قرابه مئه
واربعه وسبعين الفا بحسب احصائيات عام
2017 اي انهم لا يحملون اي جنسيه فقط
يحملون وثائق السفر خاصه للاجئين
الفلسطينيين في لبنان
طبعا هذا يحصل بالرغم من وجودهم الطويل في
لبنان فقد استبعد اللاجئون من الجوانب
الرئيسيه للحياه الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه والاقتصاديه في البلاد وفقا
للمبدا القانوني القاضي بالمعامله بالمثل
فهم تم تعريفهم بموجب القانون بانهم اجانب
فقد تم منعهم من مزاوله اكثر من 30 مهنه
منها جميع المهن الحره
لم تضف تعديلات اجريت على انظمه العمل
اللبنانيه عام 2010 شيئا يذكر لتغيير وضع
اللاجئين الاجتماعي ما دفع بكثيرين الى
الهجره اذ اظهرت دراسه اجريت عام 2010 ان
نصف عدد اللاجئين المسجلين لدى الاونروا
فقط كان يقيمون في لبنان وقد اختار البقيه
العمل في دول الخليج واوروبا
سنناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من بيروت
ابراهيم حيدر الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
وسهلا بك استاذ ابراهيم اذا يعني في
الواقع
يعني انطلاقا مما حدث في مخيم عين الحلوه
وبغض النظر عن الطريقه التي تم حلها تم
التوصل الى اطلاق وقف لاطلاق النار ولكن
نتحدث عن وضع الفلسطينيين بشكل عام داخل
لبنان ما هي اكبر التحديات التي تواجههم
نعم تحيه لك يعني الحقيقه ان
الوضع الفلسطيني في لبنان او تجمع السكاني
الفلسطيني في لبنان او ما يصطلح على
تسميته باللاجئين الفلسطينيين
يعبر اليوم عن ازمه ومشكله كبيره هي لا
تزال مستمره اصلا من ايام اللجوء
الفلسطيني منذ عام 1948 ولكن يمكن ان نفصل
ما بين مرحلتين يعني في الوجود الفلسطيني
في لبنان مرحله ما قبل 1982 ومرحله ما بعد
1982 يعني هذا هذا التاريخ هو تاريخ خروج
يعني منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه المسلحه
التي كانت في الاراضي اللبنانيه بعد
الاجتياح الاسرائيلي وبعد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ثم ما بعد عام 1982
تشتت الوضع الفلسطيني وانحشر في المخيمات
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي لم يعد هناك وظيفه
للسلاح الذي كان موجودا على يعني مستوى
الاراضي اللبنانيه كلها المشكله اليوم
يعني في الوضع الفلسطيني ليست فقط هي
مشكله امنيه وان كانت هذه المشكله الامنيه
قائمه خصوصا في مخيم عين الحلوه على ما
نشهده من
اشتباكات وشراع على النفود ولكن ايضا هي
مشكله اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
ويعاني منها لبنان بشكل عام خصوصا اليوم
اعتدنا في السياسه اللبنانيه هناك انقسام
بشان ملفات كثيره منها هذا الملف الملف
الفلسطيني كيف انعكس هذا الانقسام على وضع
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
نعم يعني
لنحدد اولا ان الوجود الفلسطيني اليوم
موجود في المخيمات في اثنا عشر مخيما
موزعين على مختلف المناطق اللبنانيه خصوصا
مخيم عين الحلوه
اليوم يعني كل ما كل ما يحدث في المخيمات
من حدث امني معين ينعكس مباشره على المحيط
الوضع اللبناني العام لان
ما يحدث احيانا ليس فقط يعني صراع نفوذ
داخل المخيمات وانما هو ايضا محاوله توظيف
يعني من جهاز لبنانيه ونستغل الوقت لانه
لم يبقى الكثير يعني هذه الامور تتكرر ما
الذي يمكن ان تفعله الحكومه اللبنانيه
فعلا لكي توقف ما الذي يقيد الحكومه
اللبنانيه لكي تضع حدا
لهذا الامر وتمنع تكرارها
الحكومه اللبنانيه هي
هي خليط من ممثلي القوى السياسيه والطوائف
اللبنانيه وبالتالي هناك انقسام في الموقف
من الوجود الفلسطيني في في لبنان وهناك
انقسام في التعاطي مع الملفات الفلسطينيه
ان كانت على المستوى السياسي او المستوى
الامني او على المستوى الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي النقطه الاساسيه ان الحكومه
اليوم في وضعها الراهن كما كانت يعني في
كما كانت الحكومات السابقه لا تستطيع فعلا
ان تحل هذه الازمه من دون ان تكون هناك
يعني تدخلات اقليميه او تسويه على مستوى
عم تتعلق بالوجود الفلسطيني النقطه
الاساسيه ان معالجه الوضع الفلسطيني لا
يمكن ان تتم على مستوى امني يعني لا يمكن
ان نعالج ان تعالج الحكومه الملفات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه للفلسطينيين من
خلفيه امنيه وبالتالي هذه الحكومه عاجزه
نتيجه الانقس
ام اللبناني العام يعني ليست الفلسطيني
وانما في ملفات الفكره شكرا جزيلا لك
ابراهيم حيدر الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من
بيروت
[موسيقى]
ونختم بهذه الخاطره العالم يتغير والمؤكد
اننا سنسمع عن امور خطيره عنوانها الذكاء
الاصطناعي الحديث هنا تحديدا عن المقاطع
والصور المزيفه او المواد التي تخضع
للتلاعب والتي تنتشر عبر الانترنت تشير
الدراسات الى ان النساء من ابرز ضحايا
المواد المزيفه بواسطه الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتكثر عبر وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
والاوروبيه شهادات تدلي بها اكاديميات او
ناشطات صدمنا عندما راينا وجوههن في
محتويات مزيفه غير لائقه طبعا مشان هذه
الصور المزيفه والمسيئه ان تدمر سمعه
الشخص تدمر عائلته من خلال استخدامها بهذه
الطريقه غير السليمه وطبعا هناك بارقه امل
لان كثير من شركات الذكاء الصناعي الان
تتحدث عن امكانيه لتمييز الصوره المزيفه
وانها لن تسمح باستمرار هذا والاضرار
حياه الناس شكرا في
[موسيقى]